Here's the truth.
I work with people all the time who tell
me incredible things and then say, "Do
you really think anyone wants to hear
what I have to say?" And when people say
that to me, I tell them this. I spend a
week at a yoga retreat center teaching
storytelling to about a dozen people.
The deal I have with them is this. You
never have to speak if you don't want
to. Come in like a mushroom. Sit down
and learn. No one ever does that except
for once someone did. A woman, she
actually sat right next to me all week
long and never said a word. On the last
day of our class, a Sunday morning,
people are going around and sharing
stories and my mushroom to my right
finally makes a sound. She says, "Well,
I have something. I just don't know if
anyone would want to hear it." And I
said, "Well, tell it to us and we'll
decide." So this is the story she tells
us. She says she was doing yoga one
night till about 7 o'clock and then she
got in her car and for the first time in
a long time she had felt peace. She had
finally sort of let go of the anger and
resentment inside her and she was
feeling good as she was driving home.
And then this car came barreling up
behind her like tailgating her weaving
all over the road. And then all of that
time she spent finding centeredness and
peace in that yoga class, it was gone.
Instantly she was angry at the person
behind her. And then that person flew
around her, went ahead and hit a pole,
wrapped the car around a telephone pole.
So she pulled over, she got out of the
car, and she ran over and she found the
driver behind the wheel very badly
injured. So she called 911. Now she was
up in the Birkshars in Massachusetts,
sort of in the middle of nowhere. And so
the 911 operator said, "I need you to
begin administering first aid cuz the
ambulance is going to take a while to
get there." So listening to the 911
operator, she begin working on this man
behind the wheel. Eventually, the
ambulance arrives and they take over,
but the ambulance driver says, "I need
you to follow me to the hospital because
you were with him for the first 10
minutes. The doctors might want to talk
to you." She's annoyed about the whole
thing, but she agrees to go. So, she
follows the ambulance to the hospital
and she takes her place in the waiting
room to see if the doctors need to talk
to her. While she's waiting in the
waiting room, a woman walks in, her best
friend. She says, "What are you doing
here?" And her best friend says, "My
husband was just in a car accident. He
put his car into a telephone pole." The
woman had never met her best friend's
husband before. They had never
encountered each other because the
husband worked the night shift and so
they had never seen each other. The
husband dies.
That man who she treated died shortly
thereafter. And her best friend says to
her, "I'm so glad that in my husband's
final moments on this earth, he was with
someone I loved."
She tells us that story in that
workshop, my mushroom who doesn't speak
all week. And then she says to us, "Do
you really think that's a story anyone
would want to hear?" At that point,
we're all crying. And I can't imagine
what it takes or what might have
happened to this woman to think that
that story doesn't want to be heard by
everyone. And yet, here's the truth. I
work with people all the time who tell
me incredible things and then say, "Do
you really think anyone wants to hear
what I have to say?" And what I always
tell people is this. If it means
something to you, it will mean something
to other people, too. I think the
tragedy of this world is that many of us
walk through the world thinking that the
moments of our lives are meaningful only
to us when the world needs to hear your
stories. The world needed to hear that
woman's story and yet she sat there for
a week wondering if anyone wanted to
hear it. I don't want that to be the
case for you. If you have something in
your heart, in your mind that means
something to you, that touches your
heart and mind in a meaningful way, I
promise you other people want to hear
it, too. They'll even want to hear it if
you tell it poorly.
The right story told poorly is still a
great story to tell. So ask yourself,
does it mean something to me?
And if it does, I promise you it will
mean something to others, too.
[Music]